clayton kershaw gets you to a two-strike
count you can pretty much feel like you
are out they're just trying to survive
up there comes downhill with a
two-strike pitch he gets him to chase a
fastball up to gone
got a new baseball delivers a 2-2 to
walker and strikes him out looking at
the knees to finish off for one two
three first up the second goes seeger
and the dodgers with something brewing
for cody bellinger
[Applause]
off the hands to first walker steps in
the bag guns to second ricochets off
ahmed nobody can find it and heads up
base running by seeger to come into
score
dodgers have a first any lead one
nothing
oh some sloppy defense that helped the
dodgers win the game last night and a
ball that chris taylor put in play
that is banged into left center field
base hit chris taylor to drive home max
muncie and it's two nothing dodgers
two strikeouts in the first inning
clayton kershaw now one shy of 2500 for
his career and three shy of the hall of
famer christy mathewson
curve ball for his third strike guard of
the night and strikeout number 2500 and
clayton kershaw's career congratulations
clayton that is quite an accomplishment
i know he only has so much room on his
shelf but don't you want to save that
one
yeah they rolled that one out he's got
four strikeouts tonight he's got
2501 in his career with his next one
time maddie 02 pitch
he struck him out on the corner and on
three pitches
he is tied christy matthewson in the
all-time strike outlets
that is amazing we look at him tied with
that name
one of the all-time great names in
baseball history back in the early 1900s
and a guy that people still talk about
christie matthewson and kershaw is right
there
and we'll pass him with his next one
the 3-2 from kershaw castro fastball
call strike three and that'll end the
inning two strikeouts and inning
the first three
dodgers two nothing we go to the bottom
of the third john peterson over one
here's the 2-0 from weaver with two outs
and there's a high fly ball hit to deep
center but castro's back and on the
warning track makes the catch
and that will retire the side third
straight inning now weaver set the side
down in order and he's retired the last
10 straight dodgers just like that
arizona has the tying run aboard
gets varsho swinging it was as if
varshall gave up on that curve and then
had that moment flash through his mind
and say wait a minute this is a kershaw
curve ball it's coming back down isn't
it he gave it a weak flail and a miss
the eighth strikeout two on two out the
nine hitter carson kelly eight k's two
walks no hits against kershaw two
nothing lead for the dodgers in the
fifth inning
there they go here it comes a curve is
swatted up the middle on a bounce it's
hernandez to finish off the fifth
no hits against kershaw through five
here's austin barnes the catcher
swinging at a miss
dowd swinging his barnes five strikeouts
for luke weaver and he's retired the
last 13 dodgers in order one two three
fourth consecutive inning they've gone
down
one away for calhoun
bounce to hernandez
kind of unsure if he wanted to charge it
away back on it but he made the play two
up two down on just four pitches
he has averaged six innings a start this
year and he's right there right now
payoff
chopper
backhand hernandez
then he came off the bag
high throw hernandez gave it a try but a
little bit high billing dread to come
off to catch it and an infield single
the first hit of the night against
kershaw
walker at first two out curve shot of
peralta
2-2
sharply hit but right at the defense
muncie fields it flips to seeger and
ends the inning seeger at second muncie
at first
dodgers looking for their first run
since the first inning here comes the
3-1 and taylor on the ground
too short ahmed the short route to
second for the force play and bergen
came in did the job and arizona has the
tying on the board with nobody out
[Applause]
after third muncie gets one
and they can't turn two ahmed's home and
the diamondbacks are on the board it's
2-1
pollock still batting for peterson
dodgers leading a 2-1 pollock on the
first pitch a fly ball to center field
drifting back to the wall of castro it's
gone a home run
aj pollock pinch hitting for peterson
the first pitch he sees he hits us over
the wall in straightaway center and the
dodgers take a 3-1 lead
ground ball base hit to center
betts brings home hernandez and the lead
is four to one
two out rbi single for mookie bench
and just like that the tying run comes
to the plate first and third two gone a
one-two pitch from blake trine
rolled to shore sega will go to second
and that's the inning
mcgee delivers and strikes him out and
the dodgers win their tenth in a row at
home